débuter nos travaux
merci monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues nous sommes heureux
d'accueillir ce matin pour la première
fois de vendre votre commission monsieur
Jean-Noël barreau ministre délégué en
charge de la transition numérique et des
télécommunications depuis juillet 2022
en décembre 2020 nous avions entendu
Cédric o votre prédécesseur dans le
cadre de nos travaux relatifs à
l'empreinte environnementale du
numérique cette question sera sans doute
évoquée par mes collègues mais nous
souhaitions plus particulièrement
aborder avec vous un autre sujet
également sujet cher à notre commission
la fracture numérique dans nos
territoires l'actualité ne manque pas en
matière d'aménagement numérique entre la
publication récente du plan de fermeture
du réseau cuivre d'orange l'accélération
du déploiement des réseaux numériques en
particulier s'ajustant de la fibre
optique et l'annonce pour 2023 d'une
réactualisation de la feuille de route
du gouvernement matière d'inclusion
numérique sujet indissociable de celui
de l'accès au réseau
afin de lancer les débats permettez-moi
de vous interroger sur deux points
n'ayant trait à la fibre optique dans un
premier temps je souhaiterais aborder la
question de la couverture de la zone
d'initiative privée qui suscite des
inquiétudes grandissantes
concernant la zone très dense certains
départements tels que la
Meurthe-et-Moselle est Nord affiche des
taux de couverture de 70%. ce qui est
nettement inférieur à la moyenne de la
zone qui avoisine des 90% pour quelle
raison ces retards de déploiement
subsistent-ils dans cette zone pourtant
considérée comme commercial allemand
rentable pour les opérateurs
nous avons abordé cette question il y a
exactement un mois avec la présidente de
l'ARSEP l'autre de la Rodière qui a
indiqué ne pas être défavorable à l'idée
d'une reprise en main des secteurs dans
lesquels une carence à l'initiative
privée et constatée
reprise en main par les collectivités
territoriales ou par les opérateurs dans
le cadre de nouveaux appels à
manifestation d'intérêt d'investissement
quelle est la prestation du gouvernement
sur cette proposition
ensuite concernant les zonami comme vous
le savez et non seulement orange accuse
de sérieux retard pour couvrir la zone
sur laquelle elle avait souscrit des
engagements contraignants mais les
déploiements ralentissent orange a réagi
à la mise en demeure prononcée par
l'arcepe en déclenchant deux procédures
contentieuses à l'encontre du régulateur
l'une pour contester cette mise en
demeure et l'autre pour contester la
constitutionnalité du pouvoir de
sanction de la recette
et du caractère opposable des
engagements pris par Orange d'autre part
lors de la Rodière a bien évidemment
fustigé cette démarche évoquant ici même
devant notre commission une tentative
d'arracher son sifflet au gendarme des
télécoms
à seulement deux ans de l'échéance de
2025 prévus pour la généralisation de la
fibre doit-on craindre une remise en
cause des objectifs qui ont été assignés
aux opérateurs en matière de déploiement
des réseaux
cela est d'autant plus inquiétant pour
ne pas dire paradoxal que vous avez
récemment annoncé l'instauration d'un
droit au très haut débit pour tous
comment envisagez-vous les contours de
ce nouveau service universel et de
quelle manière sera-t-il pris en charge
par les opérateurs
dans un second temps j'aimerais évoquer
la question des raccordements longs et
complexe à la fibre qui touche
particulièrement les territoires ruraux
le nombre de prises concernées est
difficile à évaluer il pourrait varier
entre 600 000 et 2 millions selon les
estimations le gouvernement a prévu un
budget de 150 millions d'euros pour
aider les collectivités territoriales
suivantées de tels raccordement en zone
RIP alors que la vie de nombreux acteurs
les besoins pourraient dépasser le
milliard d'euros et de vous parvenu à
évaluer précisément le nombre de prises
concernées et les coûts qui en découlent
ces éléments sont en effet nécessaire à
la définition d'une politique de
financement adéquate deux points sont
par ailleurs l'objet de critiques d'une
part le choix d'un dispositif d'appel à
projet plutôt que d'un financement
pérenne
par exemple à travers la mise en place
d'un fond dédié vous raccordement
complexes et d'autre part l'absence de
prise en compte des différences de
territoriales dans les modalités
d'attribution des aides puisque les
subventions de l'État sont limitées à
12,5% des dépensés lisibles pour tous
les porteurs de projets envisagez-vous
monsieur le ministre une évolution du
dispositif sur ces deux points celui
joue celle à présent la parole pour
répondre à ces quelques questions j'en
profite pour saluer la présence de notre
collègue Patrick chaise
en sa qualité de président du groupe
d'études numériques puis je laisserai à
mes collègues le soin de vous interroger
je vous souhaite la parole merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs je vous remercie pour votre
présence après quelques
soirées particulièrement tardives qui
vous ont occupé ces dernières jours ces
derniers jours et je vous remercie pour
cette invitation à échanger ce matin à
propos des sujets incontournables pour
nos territoires que vous avez évoqué
monsieur le Président je pense au
déploiement des des réseaux et en
particulier de la fibre question des
raccordements complexes questions des
retards de déploiement dans certaines
parties de la zone d'initiative privée
puis la question de l'inclusion
numérique thème sur lequel la madame la
sénatrice Patricia demain c'est et
vous-même monsieur le Président avait
rendu un rapport il y a quelques mois
qui rejoint de très près l'analyse que
le gouvernement a porté sur cette
question fondamentale
je précise avant d'entrer dans le détail
que j'ai engagé depuis quelques semaines
une série de visites afin d'aller
directement à la rencontre de nos
concitoyens pour échanger avec eux des
enjeux liés au numérique aux questions
qu'ils soulève aux inquiétudes et aux
intérêts
cette démarche est l'essence même du
rôle de votre commission et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je serais ravi de
compter sur votre présence lors de ces
prochains déplacements dont je manquerai
pas de vous tenir informé la priorité de
ce de ce Tour de France
si je peux l'appeler ou le qualifier
ainsi
et de
et de rendre visite au territoire et
bassin de vie dont nous savons qu'il
souffre davantage d'éloignement tant en
matière de connectivité
de couverture mobile de raccordement
fibres en matière de facilité d'usage
des outils numériques
outre les besoins et difficultés des
habitants de ces territoires éloignés de
ces usages nous faisons également face à
de nouvelles pratiques professionnelles
depuis la crise de la covid avec
l'instauration du télétravail et donc
devoir donner à chacun à tous nos
concitoyens les moyens d'accéder au
réseau et ainsi d'en profiter pour
revitaliser certains de nos territoires
c'est une question d'attractivité de
notre pays mais également d'aménagement
du territoire ce qu'il s'agit de
permettre à chaque région chaque
département chaque bassin de vie
d'offrait à ses habitants la capacité
d'être connecté protéger
et actif dans la société numérique
c'est pour répondre à ces enjeux que le
gouvernement a lancé deux grandes
politiques publiques le plan France très
haut débit initié il y a 10 ans et le
New Deal mobile initié il y a 5 ans ces
deux démarches ont été saluées pour leur
efficacité leur gouvernance et leur
bonne maîtrise budgétaire l'une par
France stratégie lors de son rapport
remis en janvier pour la le plan France
très haut débile la fibre l'autre par la
Cour des comptes en septembre 2021 pour
le New Deal mobile en 2017 le président
de la République s'est exprimé pour
mettre fin aux zones blanches et plus
récemment à porter une promesse forte
celle de la généralisation de la fibre
en à l'horizon 2025 cet engagement a
permis de placer la France dans le
peloton européen de peloton de tête des
pays européens les mieux connectés et
les plus fibrés 80% des Français ont
accès un abonnement fibre ce qui se
succès était possible grâce à l'action
collective de tous et je tiens à
remercier à travers vous les les élus
qui ont très largement contribué à la
mise en oeuvre de ces deux plans le plan
français au débit et le nudile mobile
aux côtés évidemment des opérateurs tant
d'infrastructures que commerciaux et aux
côtés de l'État ma conviction et ma
mission c'est de permettre à l'ensemble
des Français d'avoir accès au très haut
débit cela passe par une mobilisation de
l'ensemble des acteurs sur les enjeux
d'achèvement d'installation des réseaux
mais aussi de vigilance dans le cadre de
plan du décomissionnement du cuivre dès
mon arrivée et suite aux nombreuses
sollicitations et réclamations dont
vous-même être parfois les premières les
premiers récepteurs concernant la
qualité parfois décevante du déploiement
de la fibre j'ai orienté mon action en
priorité sur cet enjeu capital en lien
étroit d'ailleurs avec les
parlementaires les plus investibles sur
ce sujet au premier rang desquels
Patrick chaise que je remercie pour ça
présence
la réponse est faite sans tarder la
filière
Télécom à l'automne a pris un certain
nombre d'engagements de devant moi et
devant la présidente de la recette
s'agissant du renforcement de la qualité
des interventions la renforcement des
contrôles et la reprise des
infrastructures dégradées j'en dis
quelques mots car ces engagements sont
en bonne voie
le premier donc porte sur le
renforcement des contrôles à la fois par
la transmission
par les opérateurs commerciaux de leur
planning d'intervention et par la mise
en oeuvre de compte-rendus des
interventions réalisées permettant le
contrôle mutuel anthropérateur ça c'est
très important parce que comme vous le
savez
une grande partie des problèmes
rencontrés par nos concitoyens de
coupures de fibres sont liées à la
répartition des responsabilités entre
l'opérateur d'infrastructures et
l'opérateur commercial dans la résulte
dans le branchement d'abord puis dans la
résolution du problème la difficulté
qu'il s'agit d'entreprises différentes
qui donc avait jusqu'à présent parfois
tendance à se rejeter l'une sur l'autre
la faute concernant le
défaut de raccordement ou l'interruption
de la fibre désormais les plannings
d'intervention sont partagés les
comptes-rendus d'intervention font
l'objet de photos qui sont partagés la
responsabilité est désormais
immédiatement établie et les
erreurs sont désormais beaucoup plus
facilement corrigés ça c'est le premier
engagement il est très bien très bien
engagé le deuxième qui portait sur la
reprise des infrastructures dégradées
que ce soit au niveau des points de
mutualisation ou des réseaux
vieillissants ou mal dimensionnés et lui
aussi bien engagé donc ça c'est un
deuxième problème qui explique les les
mécontentement de nos concitoyens et qui
provenaient du fait que certains des
réseaux qui avaient été déployés vous
avez été parfois avant même le lancement
du Plan France très haut débit je pense
au département de l'Essonne par exemple
et donc ces départements précurseurs
paradoxalement se sont retrouvés dans
une situation où les réseaux avaient été
conçus sur la base d'un cahier des
charges qui était peut-être un petit peu
moins je dirais protecteur que celui
établit au moment du lancement du plan
français au débit et donc c'est réseau
apparaissaient comme par apparaissent
comme particulièrement accidentogène
c'est-à-dire que les accidents les les
défauts de service étaient plus nombreux
que sur d'autres réseaux établis plus
récemment
les opérateurs d'infrastructures
concernés par ces réseaux accidentogènes
et défaillants ont tous remis à la
recette un plan de reprise de ces
réseaux qui concernent 1000 points de
mutualisation correspondant à 450 000
locaux
et j'ai pu constater sur le terrain que
dans certains de ces départements la
reprise de ces réseaux et en très bonne
voie le troisième engagement pris par la
filière c'était celui d'une amélioration
de la qualité des interventions par le
biais d'une meilleure formation et
labilisation des techniciens sur ce
sujet le la mise en oeuvre de
l'engagement n'est pas encore tout à
fait abouti et je souhaite que les
opérateurs accélèrent sur sur ce sujet
ils ont travaillé à la rédaction d'un
cahier des charges définissant une
certification et les compétences
minimales requises sur le raccordement
final cette mesure vise à terme à une
revalorisation générale de la filière et
à une exigence de qualité au service
d'une commission efficace et fiable
en principe d'ici avril cet engagement
devrait être respecté j'y veillerai très
attentivement parce que c'est le
troisième élément de ce triptyque
reprise des réseaux des réseaux
défaillants partage efficace de
l'information pour l'attribution des
responsabilités en cas de défaut de
service et amélioration de la qualité de
l'intervention par la technicienne par
les techniciens
voilà ce qui nous a beaucoup
occupé au deuxième semestre 2022 nous
sommes dorénavant un moment charnière
dans le déploiement du très haut débit
et surtout de la fibre vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le Président la plupart
des prises faciles déployables ont été
déployés et nous devons dorénavant faire
face à ce qu'on appelle communément les
raccordements complexes ainsi qu'au
retard dans les engagements du diplôme
dans notamment dans les zones amies les
opérateurs ont chacun annoncé un plan
des commissionnements de G et 3G entre
2025 et 2026 pour la première
technologie et à l'horizon 2030 pour la
seconde et enfin orange a officialisé
son plan de décomissionnement du cuivre
et des premières expérimentations
ont d'ores et déjà commencé d'autres
prendront la suite dès 2024 avec
notamment une zone très dense incluant
la ville de Rennes et celle devant nous
devons gouvernement comme représentation
nationale être pragmatique sur les
retards d'installation
et comprendre quels sont parfois les
raisons qu'elles ont parfois des raisons
profondes et structurelle qui ont
ralenti le déploiement de la fibre notre
objectif commun doit être de rattraper
ce retard et de permettre à tous nos
concitoyens d'avoir accès à ses réseaux
pour cela nous avons deux leviers sur
lequel nous pouvons jouer
celui qui a été le plus utilisé jusqu'à
présent c'est celui des sanctions et du
contentieux c'est un levier qui me
paraît évidemment indispensable
lorsqu'il faut tenir les acteurs et en
particulier les opérateurs à leur
engagement mais je crois qu'il nous faut
doubler cette approche qui repose sur la
sanction par une approche qui repose sur
l'action et sur les incitations que nous
pouvons donner à l'ensemble des parties
prenantes de ce grand chantier qui celui
du déploiement de la fibre pour cela il
est nécessaire de trouver un point
d'équilibre et de prendre en compte les
problématiques structurelles qui
s'imposent aux opérateurs et qui
finissent par produire les
ralentissements évoqués il me semble que
c'est avec cette approche nouvelle que
nous pourrons mener à bien le
déploiement de la fibre c'est le cap que
je me fixe pour les deux années à venir
et ce travail a déjà bien commencé il
s'agit de faire preuve de responsabilité
pour engager les discussions avec
l'ensemble des acteurs et trouver les
compromis nécessaires pour paramétrer
les derniers réglages et faire ce
travail de dentelle en clair notre
objectif dans les prochains mois
l'objectif du premier semestre 2023
c'est de trouver un accord global avec
l'ensemble des acteurs afin de garantir
la promesse présidentielle d'une
généralisation du de la fibre et donc du
très haut débit cette négociation
globale elle doit permettre d'assurer la
complétude d'abord sur l'ensemble du
réseau je pense notamment à des
territoires ou aucun engagement
d'opérateur n'est prévu comme c'est le
cas en zone très dense mais aussi sur
les prises complexes qui nécessitent du
temps et des moyens
première chose c'est la complétude la
deuxième des choses c'est de garantir au
ménage les moins aisées d'autant plus
dans une période d'inflation un tarif
abordable et accessible comme cela était
déjà le cas sur l'abonnement
téléphonique simple sur le réseau cuivre
c'est la deuxième le deuxième élément de
de cette de cet accord global que nous
devons trouver avec l'ensemble des
partis prenantes troisième c'est que les
éléments les événements récents sur le
plan climatique énergétique nous pousse
assurer une résilience de nos réseaux
essentiels pour garer entière notamment
la sécurité de de des communications il
me semble que l'ensemble de ces enjeux
la complétude la résilience et
l'abordabilité pour nos concitoyens doit
irriguer les discussions avec les
opérateurs vous l'aurez compris dans
cette dernière phase si l'on peut dire
dans cette nouvelle phase du Plan France
très haut débit ou nous devons nous
atteler à la partie la plus la plus
complexe et à la bascule du cuivre vers
la fibre les opérateurs vont devoir
franchir une marche nouvelle et porter
une grande partie de l'effort comme ils
l'ont fait depuis le début du plan
France rose débit mais nous devons aussi
réfléchir comme nous avons su le faire
avec le plan français au débit qui a été
soutenu par l'État comme nous l'avons
vu avec le nude d'immobil lui aussi
soutenu par l'État nous devons
identifier un certain nombre de leviers
pour accompagner la mise en oeuvre de
ces engagements de la part des
opérateurs il nous semble qu'une des
pistes possibles
parmi d'autres et celles de la réforme
de
l'hifair à laquelle nous travaillons sur
laquelle nous discutons aujourd'hui avec
les associations
d'élus les annonces récentes des
opérateurs sur leur stratégie de dépose
de la 2G et de la 3G dans les 5
prochaines années nous incite à cette
réforme nécessaire et indispensable
pourquoi
parce que la dépose de la 2G de la 3G va
conduire si nous ne faisons rien à une
forte baisse à quelques dans quelques
années des recettes y faire aux mains
des collectivités il s'agit nullement si
nous envisageons une réforme de cette
impôt de supprimer
ces ressources à destination des
communes et départements mais au
contraire de les stabiliser et de leur
garantir une prévisibilité dans les dans
les années à venir
et pour autant le paramètre âge de la
réforme et l'ambition qu'elle porte
dépendra avant toute la négociation
que nous trouverons avec les opérateurs
et les contreparties en termes de
déploiement qui sont prêts à porter tant
sur le fixe que sur le motif autrement
dit ce que nous voudrions essayer de
faire avec l'hyper c'est de d'obtenir à
la fois une plus grande visibilité pour
les collectivités comme pour les
opérateurs et en contrepartie de cette
plus grande visibilité et bien d'obtenir
de la part des opérateurs ces
engagements que j'évoquais juste avant
en matière de complétude de résilience
et d'abord d'habilité cette réforme elle
doit se faire donc si elle se fait en
faveur de l'aménagement numérique des
territoires
en parallèle l'État devra s'engager
pleinement dans l'aménagement des
Numériques des territoires car il peut
être envisageait envisageable qu'il ne
relève du seul ressort et de la seule
responsabilité des opérateurs nous avons
aussi conscience que pour certains de
nos concitoyens le passage à la fille
peut au casinier des coûts via des
travaux parfois importants au sein de
leur propriété vous l'avez évoqué
monsieur le Président un star des aides
de l'État pour les ménages les moins
aisés qui souhaitent installer par
exemple des bandes de recharge pour les
voitures électriques nous pourrions
imaginer un mécanisme similaire pour
accéléra transition du cuivre vers la
fibre pour nos concitoyens cela
répondrait aux besoins croissants en
connectivité mais aussi et nous ne
pouvons rester insensible face à cette
réalité à la nécessité environnementale
de d'éteindre le réseau cuit j'ai pu
l'évoquer lundi lors de la remise du
rapport produit par larsep et l'ADEME
passer de l'ADSL à la fibre permet de
diminuer l'empreinte écologique du
réseau de presque 60% et une baisse de
prix pour cent de la consommation du
numérique voici en quelques lignes la
feuille de route s'agissant des réseaux
pour pour ce semestre il ne faut pas
laisser de côté pour autant le mobile le
New Deal mobile a permis de résorber
plusieurs milliers de zones blanches
depuis son lancement il y a 5 ans
l'identification décide du dispositif de
couverture ciblée prendra fin en 2025
avec une mise en service des dernières
antennes attribuées pour 2027 pour
autant le New Deal mobile comporte
d'autres actions de couverture comme
vous le savez qui sont essentielles pour
la connectivité de nos concitoyens et
pour favoriser l'attractivité de nos
territoires les opérateurs sont en effet
engagés à une couverture des axes
routiers prioritaires et ferroviaires
ainsi qu'à une couverture à l'intérieur
des bâtiments des trains et des voitures
les actions se poursuivront donc au delà
de de 2024 la généralisation d'une très
bonne couverture 4G reste un engagement
fort des opérateurs 99,6% de la
population devra bénéficier avec ces 4G
en 2027 et 99,8% d'ici
2031 une version améliorée du dispositif
sera peut-être nécessaire et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons demandé
à
au service de l'anct d'engager un
travail de recensement auprès des
équipes projets locales les plus équipes
projets départementales qui décident de
la localisation des antennes nudiles
pour identifier le besoin encore présent
d'une couverture de qualité je dirais
juste en conclusion un mot sur
l'inclusion numérique pour dire que nous
allons nous avons engagé des travaux
avec l'ensemble des acteurs de
l'inclusion numérique élus locaux et
associations d'élus association engagées
pour l'inclusion numérique de façon à
donner corps aux propositions du rapport
de Patricia demas et du président
Longeot c'est-à-dire à
structurer localement si l'on peut dire
cette politique nouvelle qui est celle
de l'inclusion numérique qui jusqu'à
présent comme le rapport la très bien
identifié et
mener de manière
insuffisamment coordonnée par un grand
nombre d'acteurs sur les avec toi il
nous faut donc grâce si l'on peut dire à
la première brique qui a été posée en
2021 avec le recrutement des 4000
conseillers numériques et bien donner à
cette politique une une visibilité une
structure une pérennité au niveau des
bassins de vie de façon à ce que et bien
dans chacun de nos territoires nos
concitoyens sachent vers qui se tournait
lorsqu'il s'agit de de trouver un
accompagnement vers les
usages numériques ce travail je dirais
très ascendant
va donner lieu à une restitution à la
fin de l'hiver au début du printemps
c'est-à-dire dans quelques jours et va
nous permettre et bien d'établir cette
feuille de route qui engagera non
seulement l'État mais l'ensemble de ces
acteurs de cette nouvelle politique
publique que nous avons construit
ensemble voilà ce que je pouvais dire en
introduction et en réponse à vos
questions monsieur le Président merci
encore pour votre accueil merci monsieur
le ministre avant de donner la parole à
mes collègues que je voudrais saluer
la présence aux auditeurs de l'Institut
du Sénat qui viennent se former pour
mieux connaître effectivement les
méthodes de travail de notre assemblée
je vous souhaite la bienvenue
et je vais
avant de donner la parole je vous
informe que je céderais la présidence de
la Commission à 11h30 à Didier mandeli
parce que compte tenu des 27 nuits la
Conférence des Présidents a lieu à 11h45
donc il faut que j'aille à la Conférence
des Présidents 11h45 donc Didier modély
sur la présidence de la commission je
vais donner la parole à Jean-Michel
Houlgate merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre donc merci pour
pour vos précisions en effet donc le
plan France très haut débit et le New
Deal mobile je dirais son en plein
déploiement je voudrais vous demander
quelques précisions vous n'avez pas et
répondu à la question du président
notamment sur les raccordements longs et
complexes puisqu'on sait très bien que
la règle des 80-20 fait que en règle
générale les 20% qui restent à faire
vont demander des efforts notamment dans
les zones RIP en milieu rurale avec des
surcoûts qui sont extrêmement
conséquents donc savoir quel est votre
sentiment est-ce que est-ce que il y a
des financesments supplémentaires qui
vont être qui vont être stabiliser pour
permettre justement d'arriver à ce
peut-être pas ce 100% mais à arriver à
tangente les objectifs tels qu'ils
avaient été assignés par la technologie
fibre de deuxième élément donc vous nous
avez parlé du triptyque et c'est vrai
qu'on ne peut s'en réjou on peut s'en
réjouir mais est-ce que selon vous c'est
suffisant est-ce qu'à un moment donné il
ne faudra pas comment dirais-je d'une
certaine façon passer à un mode beaucoup
plus coercitif à savoir supprimer tout
simplement le mode stock comme le
préconise mais je pense qu'il reviendra
tout à l'heure Patrick chaise notamment
dans un certain nombre de propositions
qu'il a faite enfin pour pour compléter
le panorama concernant la fermeture du
réseau cuivre donc le premier lot de 162
communes dans lequel la fermeture du
réseau cuivre va être engagée a été
rendue publique donc en décembre dernier
or la complétude du réseau fibre n'est
pas encore assurée dans l'intégralité de
ces communes alors qu'il s'agit d'une
condition bien évidemment préalable à la
fermeture du réseau cuivre qui est
imposée à Orange donc
pas là un signal un peu incohérent et de
quel de votre point de vue quel rôle
l'État peut jouer pour justement
accompagner cette ambitieux chantier et
notamment rassurer les collectivités
territoriales et puis les usagers qui
sont un qui sont quand même relativement
inquiets enfin dernier point très rapide
sur les réseaux mobiles vous savez qu'il
y a eu de la spéculation foncière à un
moment donné qui s'était opéré et ça on
l'avait mentionné dans le cadre de de la
loi de l'excellent Patrick chaise sur la
réduction de l'empreinte
environnementale du numérique et et
cette cette loi d'ailleurs demandée
avait imposé à tout acquéreur d'un
terrain qu'il dessine à l'édification
d'un pylône dans l'informer le maire et
de lui fournir la preuve du mandat donc
ça ce problème est réglé mais néanmoins
se pose un nouveau problème qui est
celui je dirais du renouvellement des
des concessions et et à ce titre donc la
reprise des baux la reprise des baux
crée un problème puisqu'il y a des
acteurs qui promettent des loyers
conséquents aux communes sans avoir
l'assurance que le propriétaire entre
guillemets du pylône et bien lui
acceptera les conditions qui sont
imposées qui sont imposées dans le cadre
de cette reprise de Débo donc comment
comment régler ce problème est-ce que
est-ce que l'État en est conscient et ce
qu'il y a des mesures particulières que
vous envisagez de prendre
la parole à Madame demain et puis après
vous répondrez une collègue merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je souhaite donc vous
interroger sur trois points mis en avant
dans le rapport d'information de la
Commission sur l'inclusion de numérique
que nous avons publié en mars 2022 et
dont j'ai été la rapporteur premièrement
vous avez effectivement annoncé en
septembre dernier une réactualisation de
la Stratégie nationale pour un numérique
inclusif de 2018 ce dont nous pouvons
effectivement nous réjouir ne serait-ce
que pour tenir compte des
bouleversements induits par la crise
sanitaire et les usages numériques des
Français quel bilan monsieur le ministre
mais vous en avez déjà parlé tirez-vous
de cette stratégie ainsi que surtout des
principaux outils déployés comme les up
territoriaux ou les conseillers
numériques français services et surtout
pouvez-vous déjà nous donner mais j'ai
entendu la date du printemps donc
incessamment sous peu pouvez-vous donc
nous présenter les grands axes de la
future stratégie du numérique pour 2023
deuxièmement mes travaux m'avaient
conduits adressé un bilan effectivement
très critique aussi du passe numérique
l'objectif fixé en 2019 était de
distribuer un peu plus d'un million de
passes et vous le savez nous sommes très
très loin du compte avec seulement
100000 passes effectivement utilisés en
2022 la Cour des comptes d'ailleurs
n'avait pas mâché ses mots sur le sujet
et je voulais savoir quel regard vous
portez monsieur le ministre sur cet
outil après 4 ans d'une piètre mise en
oeuvre et ne serait-il peut-être pas
tant au regard des résultats pour les
moins décevants du dispositif de
concevoir un outil plus opérationnel
pour faciliter l'accès des particuliers
aux formations du numérique
troisièmement et enfin je souhaite une
fois encore attirer votre attention sur
le manque de lisibilité de la politique
nationale d'inclusion numérique pour les
élus locaux particulièrement dans les
communes rurales comme je l'avais
d'ailleurs signalé dans notre rapport
les résultats de la consultation en
ligne que nous avions mené alors sont
édifiants les dispositifs nationaux
d'inclusion numérique sont largement
méconnues par les élus locaux qui ont
répondu au sondage et qui critiquent un
manque cruel d'accompagnement et de
pédagogie surtout de la part de l'État
et ce d'autant qu'il y a un éclatement
des sources de financement qui nuit
aussi à la lisibilité et à la fiabilité
et l'efficacité de cette politique les
élus locaux sont pourtant en première
ligne pour répondre aux difficultés
rencontrées par leurs administrés dans
l'usage des outils numériques qui
n'oublions pas ouvrent l'accès à leurs
droits donc elle mesure monsieur le
ministre la réactualisation de la
stratégie nationale
permettent permettra-t-elle de répondre
à ce problème et que pensez-vous de la
proposition de notre commission
d'élaborer un guide national annuel
présentant les principaux outils en
matière d'inclusion numérique avec un
calendrier prévisionnel des appels à
projets à venir qui permettrait
d'améliorer la lisibilité je vous
remercie
monsieur le mini je vous c'est la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président sur
les questions de monsieur le sénateur
Houlgate sur les raccordements complexes
vous avez raison de dire que quand on a
fait les 80% en général les 20% qui
restent c'est un peu plus compliqué et
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans mon
propre objectif j'ai voulu vous vous
présenter notre programme de travail qui
va à la fois
s'agissant de des engagements que nous
voulons que les opérateurs puissent
prendre toucher à la complétude à la
résilience et à l'abordabilité mais qui
va nécessiter certains efforts des
opérateurs mais également un offert un
effort évidemment de l'État ce à quoi
nous réfléchissons pour la part de
l'État c'est évidemment l'accompagnement
au génie privé c'est-à-dire la
il existe aujourd'hui un guichet nous
sommes en train de réfléchir à son à son
évolution un guichet vers lequel les
concitoyens qui sont difficiles à
raccorder pour des raisons de génie
privée puisse se tourner de manière à
bénéficier d'un soutien de l'État pour
cette installation mais dans la partie
complexe de des raccords mondiaux
complexes il y a aussi une partie qui
relève du génie civil et qui est qui
devra être porté par les opérateurs
d'infrastructures
donc quand on regarde ces 20% qui nous
qui nous restent quand on regarde la
nécessité d'avoir des réseaux résilients
quand on regarde la nécessité pour
pouvoir offrir à nos concitoyens droit
au très haut débit à ce que les
opérateurs offrent des tarifs sociaux
cela suppose un investissement assez
considérable que à mon avis nous
notionnerons pas uniquement sur le
fondement de la de la menace et de la
sanction et c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'État accompagnera notamment
avec le soutien au génie privé c'est la
raison aussi pour la pour laquelle nous
voulons en contrepartie de ces
engagements que nous que nous souhaitons
que les opérateurs puissent tenir que
nous voulons réfléchir à cette plus
grande visibilité dans l'hiver qui
permettrait de donner un peu d'air aux
opérateurs grâce à cette visibilité
accrue et leur permettre d'assumer ces
obligations qui sont assez
substantielles s'agissant des 162
communes que vous évoquez
d'abord rappeler que une expérimentation
a déjà eu lieu pour une commune qui est
située dans la plus belle
circonscription de France la deuxième
des Yvelines je dis la plus belle parce
que c'est la mienne qui qui est une
commune de 1600 habitants
lévis-saint-non qui a été un bon
laboratoire parce qu'a permis de
d'identifier notamment le rôle
déterminant que joueront les élus locaux
et les mers dans la bascule définitive
du cuivre vers la fibre puisqu'en
réalité à la fin il faut il faut
convaincre un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens qui sont peut-être les plus
éloignés ou les de bon des usages qu'il
est que le moment est venu de passer du
cuivre vers la FIM on a actuellement une
expérimentation en cours avec une de
communes d'Île-de-France et des communes
du Pas-de-Calais pour laquelle la
fermeture technique du cuivre va
intervenir dans les dans les prochains
jours à la fin du mois de mars
et puis ensuite des lots de plus en plus
importants vont intervenir vous l'avez
évoqué mais en toute état de cause et
larcep a été très clair sur ce sujet une
fermeture technique ne peut intervenir
sans que la complétude ne soit assurée
donc la balle est dans le dans le camp
d'orange
et puis il s'agissant de
de la question que vous évoquez sur la
reprise
des Baules et vous avez raison de
souligner que les élus locaux et les
préfets également sont en demande
d'éclairage sur l'application de
l'article 33 de la loi 16 c'est la
raison pour laquelle le gouvernement a
rédigé un document en concertation avec
l'AMF pour expliciter la manière dont
cet article peut-être
mobilisé et nous tenons évidemment ce
guide à votre plein et entière
disposition
sur les questions de même la sénatrice
de masse
la manière dont nous avons procédé de
confier à des groupes de travail
présidé par des acteurs des associations
d'élus ou des acteurs associatifs qui
portent sur un certain nombre de sujets
sur lesquels il faut que nous
convergions et qui était bien identifié
dans votre rapport le premier c'est
celui de la gouvernance locale et du
financement de cette politique et à ce
sujet je voudrais simplement dire que
j'ai pour ma part une légère
différence d'appréciation avec la
recommandation de votre rapport qui qui
évoque peut-être
la nécessité la nécessité de ne pas
chercher un chef de fila unique dans
chaque territoire
pour ma part sans aller jusqu'à
déterminer un niveau administratif ou un
acteur de référence qui soit le même si
l'on peut dire dans tous les territoires
je souhaite que nos concitoyens et que
les acteurs locaux puissent identifier
qui est le chef de fil de cette
politique dans leur territoire je crois
qu'on pourra pas
systématiser le niveau administratif
puisque comme vous le savez dans
certains territoires j'étais il y a pas
très longtemps dans l'un avec Patrick
chaise le niveau départemental et celui
qui est peut-être le plus le plus
adéquat et qui c'est d'ores et déjà
saisi un peu de cette politique c'est le
cas dans dans l'un ou le syndicat
numérique de l'Ain a non seulement et
non seulement pleinement saisi les enfin
pleinement saisi des questions de
déploiement mais en plus sur les
questions d'inclusion coordonne
aujourd'hui l'action des conseillers
numériques sur l'ensemble du territoire
mais dans d'autres départements ou se
trouve par exemple une métropole
le
ou d'autres départements encore où on a
des bassins de vie qui sont plutôt
éclatés orientés vers vers d'autres
ères d'influence urbaine alors le
département n'est peut-être pas le
l'acteur avec le l'acteur clé pour être
pour jouer ce rôle de chef de film mais
j'aimerais en tout cas à l'issue de ces
travaux
dans chaque territoire un chef de fil
puisse être
identifié donc le premier groupe de
travail planche sur ce sujet là le
deuxième sur la structuration des des
métiers et de la formation de la
médiation à la médiation numérique
puisque nous avons avec les conseils
numériques avec les aidants connecte
avec les médiateurs une une un métier
nouveau qui émerge qui est exercée
aujourd'hui par des professionnels qui
se consacrent quasi 100% du temps à
cette tâche là mais aussi par des
professionnels des agents qui
aujourd'hui sont pas pour vocation
première des accompagnants mais qui dans
les faits leçon je pense au secrétaire
de mairie je pense aux responsable de
médiathèque par exemple qui joue un rôle
d'accueil en première ligne déterminant
et qui devrait pouvoir accès accéder eux
aussi si l'on peut dire à des formations
et à une forme de reconnaissance de leur
action en matière de médiation numérique
c'est l'objectif du deuxième groupe de
travail le troisième groupe de travail
est dédié à la question
de l'outillage de la médiation numérique
et du parcours
usagé l'outillage est une question
importante dans votre rapport vous
soulignez notamment des expérimentes
très très intéressantes partant des
conseillers numériques avec un
déploiement dans les communes grâce à
des dispositifs mobiles j'en ai j'en ai
visité un dans le département de la
Somme qui fonctionne très bien vous avez
un conseiller numérique au médiateur qui
est déployé dans les petites communes
avec une petite fourgonnette qui qui
muni d'une parabole d'équipements en
ordinateur d'équipement en tablette et
qui conventionne avec les communautés de
communes pour se déployer avec un
planning très serré dans les dans les
communes et se rapprocher au plus près
de nos concitoyens puis le quatrième
groupe de travail il est consacré à
l'évaluation de cette politique je tiens
à signaler que dans quelques jours un
nouveau rapport sur inclusion va venir
actualiser les chiffres de l'éloignement
numérique que par ailleurs nous
disposons désormais des évaluations pics
en classe de troisième qui nous
permettent de mesurer très finement au
niveau des collèges quel est le niveau
atteint par les élèves avec des
différences assez marquées de ce que
j'ai pu en voir selon selon les
territoires
je pense qu'il nous faudra réorienter
l'effort de du Pass numérique qui vous
l'avez très bien décrit dans votre
rapport n'a pas produit les effets
escomptés vers ces leviers que nous
voulons mettre à disposition de la
politique
de la politique d'inclusion au niveau
territorial avec une une
structuration au niveau national grâce
notamment
au conseiller numérique au niveau
régional avec les hub sur lesquels vous
vous dites dans le rapport avec justesse
que certains fonctionnent déjà très bien
que d'autres sont encore en phase de
rodage je crois qu'il nous faut les
accompagner parce que le niveau régional
est quand même assez pertinent notamment
pour pour aller capter un certain nombre
de financement je pense aux financement
européen les le hub des assembleurs dans
les hauts de France a réussi à les
solliciter des des financements
européens qui ensuite ruissel sur
l'ensemble des territoires et puis au
niveau local avec ce que nous sommes en
train de construire et et qui qui fera
l'objet de de d'annonces à l'issue du
travail des des groupes mais je une
nouvelle fois insister sur le fait que
les travaux que vous avez menés
auront largement inspiré ces travaux
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
donner la parole aux cinq premières
demandes monsieur gold après monsieur
Demilly madame filleul monsieur Belin
monsieur chevrolier monsieur gold merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre moi ma question va sortir un
peu du cadre de la fracture numérique
mais c'est une question qui suscite une
grande inquiétude chez les élus locaux
elle porte notamment sur la
cybersécurité ou plutôt la
cybercriminalité
qui touche les collectivités
territoriales le problème est
d'actualité le secteur public étant au
quotidien concerné par cette menace qui
peut paralyser bien sûr le
fonctionnement du service public mais
faire perdre un certain nombre de
données aussi du jour au lendemain alors
en 2020 une étude montrait que près de
30% des collectivités territoriales
avaient été victimes d'une attaque au
rançongiciel chiffre qui a fortement
augmenté depuis cette date alors si le
sujet a longtemps été laissé de côté
faute de compétences techniques par les
élus locaux
prennent aujourd'hui
désormais le problème en compte de la
pleine mesure de ce risque mais par
contre les freins persistent c'est à
dire qu'il y a pas beaucoup d'ingénierie
qualifiés le coût des dispositifs à
développer important alors vous avez
récemment lancé un vaste diagnostic pour
aider les communes et notamment les plus
petites d'entre elles apparaît les
cyberattaques diagnostic auquel
seulement 1000 communes ont répondu pour
l'instant alors face à ce constat la
mutilation au plus près des
collectivités concernées pour être
certainement un choix judicieux pour
mettre en commun les efforts affronter
les pénuries de professionnels
qualifiées et ainsi mettre en place une
protection collective je voudrais
revenir simplement sur l'exemple récent
des centres de gestion de la fonction
publique territoriale qui avait proposé
un service client en main au moment du
rgpd
alors bon ma question elle est
relativement simple c'est quelle est la
stratégie du gouvernement pour aider
justement les collectivités à se
protéger efficacement contre les
cyberattaques et puis je voudrais aussi
m'excuser parce que je pourrais pas
écouter votre votre réponse puisque j'ai
une autre obligation mais j'écouterai
attentivement cette réponse en différé
merci beaucoup
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Stéphane Demilly merci monsieur le
Président bonjour monsieur le ministre
le numérique est aujourd'hui
indispensable c'est une évidence encore
faut-il posséder des connexions vous en
avez parlé encore faut-il pousser des
outils et encore faut-il savoir les
utiliser or un français sur 6
aujourd'hui est en situation
d'électronisme dans ma région des Hauts
de France cela concernerait près de 800
000 personnes selon une étude de l'INSEE
alors certes il existe plus de 800
dispositifs d'aide dans la région mais
c'est insuffisant comme le regrette
l'association humaine Emmaüs Connect en
2018 une stratégie pourrait réduire la
fracture numérique avait été mise en
place dans ma région pilotée par la
Direction Régionale de la Jeunesse des
Sports et de la Cohésion sociale mais il
est vraiment difficile de bien
coordonner l'offre d'aide et la demande
notamment pour les plus précaires et
également pour les personnes âgées des
personnes qui au-delà du problème
technique matériel nécessite d'une
formation en présentiel et même parfois
à domicile alors comment répondre à ce
besoin précis c'est un dispositif lourd
j'en conviens mais qui est un véritable
enjeu de société lié notamment au
basculement rapide des administrations
dans la numérisation alors ce ministre
des mesures complémentaires aux
initiatives associatives et municipales
sont-elles imaginées par votre ministère
pour répondre aux besoins pédagogiques
spécifiques de cette population victime
de ce qu'on appelle donc l'électronisme
permettez-moi d'ajouter une autre
demande à mon intervention demande
générale mais vous allez le comprendre
assez intéressé monsieur le ministre
travaillez-vous avec la SNCF pour que
nous puissions avoir internet dans les
TER comme on peut la voir également dans
le TGV je prends un exemple au hasard la
ligne Amiens Paris c'est une des plus
importantes de France or vous n'avez pas
d'accès Internet dans dans le train et
comme vous n'avez pas non plus d'accès
mobile sur la ligne vous ne pouvez pas
utiliser votre mobile pour vous
connecter à Internet et ainsi vous ne
pouvez pas préparer vos réunions de
commission sénatoriale et donc ce serait
bien monsieur le ministre que vous
interveniez auprès de la SNCF pour que
nous puissions avoir internet dans le
train Amiens - Paris et vice-versa
très bien très bonne question
effectivement ça empêche de travailler
mais des fois ça laisse une certaine
tranquillité mais ça c'est pour l'humour
je vais
la parole à Madame filleul
et autant se propose une nouvelle
politique publique de lutte contre
l'électronisme moi je salue bien sûr
cette perspective en disant qu'il y a
vraiment
urgence sur le sujet La Gazette des
communes disait dans son dernier numéro
que la proportion de Français qui
n'avait pas mené à bien une démarche
administrative avait augmenté de 12
points entre 2020 et 2022 et par
ailleurs toutes les enquêtes montrent
aujourd'hui que ce ne sont pas seulement
les personnes âgées qui sont concernées
mais que les jeunes également et bien
malgré leur maîtrise des réseaux sociaux
et bien ne réussissent pas non plus à
mener à bien ces démarches
administratives et on s'inquiète de voir
que l'école n'a pas pu à ce jour prendre
le relais pour cette école numérique
donc
bravo tant mieux si nous avons enfin une
politique publique globale de lutte
contre l'électronisme pour ma part parce
que vous vous posez des questions avec
Madame de masse sur la collectivité qui
serait susceptible d'être chef de fil je
voulais vous dire que pour ma part moi
je plaisais plus tôt pour la le
département chef d'orchestre de cette
politique de lutte contre l'électronisme
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de vous le dire
parce que je pense que le département
reste un échelon de proximité qu'il a la
parfaite connaissance des acteurs de
l'action sociale et également des
acteurs associatifs que par ailleurs les
associations de départements les deux
associations ils sont tout à fait
favorables et que les départements
mènent déjà un certain nombre
d'initiatives dans ce domaine donc
plus précisément venir à ma question qui
concerne les conseillers num ériques
j'ai mené un travail dans le cadre de la
commission supérieure du numérique et
des postes à ce propos avec ma collègue
Denise Saint-Pée qui a participé
également à ce travail
et
c'est les conclusions de ce travail ont
été quelque part
étayer statistiquement par le rapport de
Pierre Mazet qui mène un travail
également sur les conseillers numériques
et ce travail montre que si les
objectifs ont été atteints sur le plan
quantitatif sur le plan qualitatif les
résultats ne sont pas exactement au
rendez-vous et tout particulièrement
pour ceux qui concerne le statut des
conseillers numériques 70% des
conseillers numériques ont en effet un
diplôme Bac+2 mais ils sont toujours
rémunérés au SMIC et leur contrat reste
précaire ils ne savent pas encore
vraiment aujourd'hui si leur poste va
être pérennisé par ailleurs sur le plan
de la formation les conseillers
numériques
notent très sévèrement la formation
qu'ils ont reçu qui n'est pas adapté au
contexte dans lequel ils ont eu à
travailler enfin et j'y reviens à
nouveau aujourd'hui
compte tenu du retard pris dans les
annonces de pérennisation de leur poste
et bien beaucoup ont déjà quitté leur
poste et son parti vers d'autres
horizons professionnelles ne pensez-vous
pas là qu'il y a un véritable problème
quelque part un gâchis humain et un
gâchis financier par rapport à
l'investissement je crois
293 millions d'euros qui a été réalisé
pour mettre en place les conseillers
numériques
merci je vais donner la parole à Bruno
Belin merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur Miss je vais venir sur un sujet
très terre à terre qui nous préoccupe
partout dans tous les territoires
essentiellement ruraux la téléphonie
mobile un truc qui existe depuis près de
30 ans sauf sur certains endroits
beaucoup en France ou parfois on a la
complexité tout simplement non pas de
l'opérateur et des procédures avec les
services de l'État
les DDT les ABS et puis vont se rajouter
demain là où il y a des documents
d'urbanisme des questions de zan ou donc
impossibilité de de mettre de nouveaux
pylônes or dans les secteurs ruraux sans
pylône pour l'instant évidemment pas de
solution donc question très simple que
compte faire les tailles que compte
faire le gouvernement que vous présenter
pour qu'il y ait une fluidité une
facilité dans les installations pour que
enfin la téléphonie mobile soit une
réalité d'accès sur tous les territoires
et notamment les territoires ruraux
c'est une question d'aménagement du
territoire et d'accessibilité et
d'équité dans l'accès un service
monsieur le ministre
merci chers collègues je vais donner la
parole à Guillaume chevrolier puis je
vais céder la présidence à Didier
mandeli
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre joueur venir sur la mise en
oeuvre de l'application de la loi sur la
réduction de l'empreinte
environnementale du numérique adopté en
2021 initiée par le président en chaise
et j'étais le corps rapporteur avec
Jean-Michel Houlgate vous le savez
l'empreinte environnementale du
numérique et c'est 60 % de l'empreinte
sont les terminaux il y avait un certain
nombre d'articles dans cette
propositions de loi notamment un article
7 qui interdit de limiter la
restauration des fonctionnalités d'un
appareil en dehors des circuits agréés
par le fabricant ou encore l'article 13
qui prévoyait des opérations de collecte
national d'équipements électriques et
électronique accompagné d'une prime au
retour donc après la mise en application
cette loi est-ce que vous avez déjà
identifié les effets de ces deux mesures
et
en mars dernier le gouvernement avait
annoncé un soutien à la filière du
reconditionnement ce qui était un point
important dans nos débats on salue le
soutien mais il y a toujours le problème
du reconditionnement qui sont enfin des
appareils reconditionniques qui sont
soumis à la redevance copie privée
est-ce que des évolutions peuvent
arriver sur ce sujet et enfin l'article
4 de la proposition de loi prévoyait la
création d'un observatoire de recherche
des impacts environnementaux placés sous
l'autorité de l'ADEME et de l'ARCEP pour
analyser et quantifier les impacts
directs et indirects du numérique
et ce que vous pouvez nous dire où en
est la mise en place de cette organisme
par ailleurs j'ai déposé récemment une
proposition de loi monsieur le ministre
pour garantir une meilleure information
dans le cadre des installations
d'antenne relais en substance cette
proposition permettrait de transférer la
responsabilité de l'information aux
administrés concernés par l'installation
d'une antenne relais de l'élu aux
opérateurs il paraît aujourd'hui
effectivement incohérent que ce soit le
maire ou le président de PCI qui n'a
aucun moyen d'empêcher les installations
d'antenne qui soit en charge de
l'information auprès des habitants de
plus cette situation laisse planer
souvent une incompréhension de la part
des habitants sur les pouvoirs des élus
en la matière donc le gouvernement
est-il favorable à une réflexion sur ce
sujet dans un contexte où les élus
locaux sont soumis à de plus en plus de
pression
et enfin j'ai une dernière question qui
porte sur la la suppression depuis le 3
décembre 2020 du service universel pour
les prestations de raccordement en
réseau et de fournitures d'un service
téléphonique cette situation n'est pas
sans poser de problème pour les
particuliers qui font construire une
maison hors lotissement puisque ils sont
maintenant
contraint de payer la charge de ce
raccordement et ce qui remonte du
terrain les sommes sont parfois
significatives entre 10 et 20.000 euros
par branchement donc je voulais savoir
Monsieur mi si vous aviez connaissance
de ces problématiques et qu'est-ce que
vous posez et vous pouvez proposer pour
comme mesure de soutien c'est
particulier merci
si vous voulez répondre c'est une liste
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président sur
la la question du sénateur
Eric gold vous dire qu'effectivement la
question de la cybersécurité et
désormais une question essentielle que
l'on pense au quotidien de nos
concitoyens de nos entreprises ou de nos
collectivités
au deuxième semestre de l'année dernière
comme vous le savez ce sont les communes
de Caen de Chaville qui ont été touchés
ce sont les départements de
Seine-Maritime des Alpes des
Alpes-Maritimes de Seine-et-Marne ce
sont la Région Guadeloupe et la région
Normandie ce sont les établissements
hospitaliers de Corbeil-Essonnes ou de
Versailles qui ont fait l'objet
d'attaque très significative et très
pénalisante pour la mise en oeuvre de
leur service aux populations
face à cela le
gouvernement a lancé en 2021 dans le
cadre du plan de relance une
un programme de cybersécurité pour nos
grandes collectivités et nos grands
établissements publics 950 de ces
grandes collectivités de ces grands
établissements publics
ont pu bénéficier de ces parcours de ces
bières sécurité qui consiste en une
phase d'audit une phase de conseil qui
doit amener à une meilleure formation
des collaborateurs et un équipement des
institutions concernées en logiciel
adapté c'est un processus relativement
long qui est délivré par l'ansy et qui
n'a pas encore tout à fait abouti pour
les 950 établissements et et
organisation
bénéficiaires ce que nous avons constaté
en revanche c'est que
parmi les collectivités que je viens qui
ont fait l'objet d'une attaque la ville
de Caen a beaucoup mieux résisté que
d'autres organisations précisément parce
qu'elle avait terminé son parcours de
cybersécurité qu'elle s'était équipée
d'une solution
dite de Dr c'est-à-dire d'antivirus
sophistiqué d'ailleurs
fourni par une entreprise française qui
s'appelle harfanglab qui lui a permis
d'identifier très en amont le début de
l'attaque et donc de mettre à l'abri ces
données les plus sensibles
je dis cela parce que suite à l'attaque
sur l'hôpital de Corbeil-Essonnes nous
avons décidé de renforcer ce programme
de cybersécurité en l'ouvrant à 150
hôpitaux supplémentaires à 50
collectivités supplémentaires ces
programmes donc continuer à suivre leur
cours pour mieux armer les grandes
collectivités établissement public mais
la question se pose aussi pour les
petites collectivités et les petites
communes en particulier
qui sont elles aussi victimes de ces
attaques
qui se multiplient et pour y répondre
nous avons souhaité que l'annecy puisse
développer un outil mutualisé sur
abonnement à destination des petites
collectivités vers lesquelles pourront
se tourner pour obtenir un nom de
domaine une messagerie qui soit
sécurisée dès l'origine nativement et à
terme également un dispositif
d'hébergement je ne sais pas vous dire à
ce stade puisque l'horizon de
déploiement de cette solution c'est la
fin de l'année 2023 je ne sais pas vous
dire si ce sera une plateforme nationale
si au contraire il s'agissera de
solutions
délivrée au niveau local notamment par
les les collectivités ou les syndicats
de collectivité en charge de la
politique numérique sur les territoires
mais notre objectif est qu'à la fin 2023
toutes les communes de France puissent
se tourner pour leur nom de domaine leur
messagerie à thème pour leur hébergement
vers une solution
sécurisée
sur les questions de sur le sénateur
Stéphane Demilly ou à je partage
évidemment sur l'électronisme
sur la nécessité que nous avons de faire
prendre de l'ampleur et de mieux
structurer cette politique là j'ai eu
l'occasion de l'évoquer tout à l'heure
et
donc pour
pour être très précis dans quelques
semaines nous nous dévoilerons l'issue
des travaux menés sur la structuration
au niveau local de cette politique là ça
gouvernance on financement la formation
des et la et l'identification des
professionnels de la médiation numérique
au sens large le parcours
usagé l'outillage de la médiation
numérique et l'évaluation de cette
politique et c'est c'est en tout cas de
la manière dont je souhaite que tous les
acteurs de cette politique soient
engagés à terme avec une bonne
identification
localement du chef de fil de cette
politique sur la question des du Amiens
Paris qui qui effectivement peut manquer
de connectivité en plus d'être parfois
presque jamais mais parfois un petit peu
en retard sur les sur les horaires
prévus
j'en ai fait j'en ai fait l'expérience
moi-même simplement rappeler que dans le
New Deal mobile
il y a les antennes qui qui ont déjà été
identifiées il y en a plus de 3000
celles qui ont déjà été déployées il y
en a plus de 2000 donc c'est autant de
zones blanches qui ont été effacées dans
la dernière phase du New Deal mobile ce
sont les axes des voies ferrées les axes
routiers qui seront plus
particulièrement ciblés et qui sont des
engagements pris par les opérateurs au
moment du lancement de ce plan-là alors
c'est pas le wifi c'est le réseau mobile
pour le wifi je prends votre suggestion
au vol et je vous propose d'en parler
avec les la direction de la SNCF pour
voir comment est-ce que le wifi pourrait
être un peu plus généralisé sur les les
remarques et les observations de la
sénatrice Martine filleul
je crois qu'il est important
effectivement de bien caractériser la
fracture numérique le rapport qui
paraîtra dans quelques jours et que
j'évoquais en réponse aux questions de
Patricia demas tout à l'heure viendra
apporter des éléments nouveaux vous avez
tout à fait raison de dire qu'il ne
s'agit pas d'une question
générationnelle il y a une dimension
générationnelle dans la fracture
numérique mais on aurait bien tort de
penser que le que ça ne que ça se résume
à une question générale
ce que je puis vous dire des analyses
que j'ai vu à ce stade des analyses que
j'ai faites à ce stade c'est qu'il y a
notamment une une très forte corrélation
entre je dirais le les compétences
numériques observées sur un territoire
et la part de la population qui a eu
accès à un diplôme de l'enseignement
supérieur c'est un peu ce que vous
disiez dans votre remarque et vous avez
tout à fait raison c'est un des éléments
qui est particulièrement
corrélés donc la fracture numérique
c'est pas uniquement un question en
générationnel c'est effets sociales il
faut l'aborder comme tel sur le chef de
fila je
voilà j'ai une position qui est un peu
intermédiaire entre la vôtre et celle de
de Patricia demas qui est de dire que
j'ai besoin d'avoir un chef de fil
identifié ne serait-ce que pour voir lui
confier moi état quelques quelques
moyens peut-être qu'il aura à l'achat de
répartir entre les acteurs de cette
politique là j'en ai j'en ai besoin mais
je je pense que j'aurais bien tort moi
état de définir à Paris quel est le
niveau administratif quelle est la
structure qui est la mieux à même d'être
le coordinateur local de cette politique
là mais nous verrons ce que les groupes
de travail nous remonterons à ce sujet
sur les conseillers numériques nous
avons annoncé il y a quelques semaines
nos structures porteuses que le
programme est bien pérennisé puisque
nous avons vous avez pérennisé les
crédits associés aux
programmes des conseillers numériques
lors de
l'examen du projet de loi de finance
2023 alors certes nous allons
progressivement diminuer la part de
l'État dans le financement des postes
des conseils numériques qui au départ
était financés à 100%. est-ce que
est-ce que ça veut dire pour autant
qu'il va y avoir moins de conseils
numériques je ne suis pas sûr parce que
je regarde moins un autre programme qui
est très important et qui est très utile
pour nos territoires qui est celui des
maisons France services qui est comme
vous le savez qu'au financer à hauteur
de 30% par l'État et qui fonctionne
plutôt bien alors les trajectoires que
pour l'un sur lesquels pour l'instant
nous avons travaillé ne vont pas aussi
bas que 30%. mais il va y avoir un
co-financement désormais des structures
porteuses ou en tout cas à terme des
incofinancement des structures porteuses
je pense pas que ça met en danger le le
programme mais on est évidemment très à
l'écoute et on a essayé d'écouter aussi
et d'être attentif dans la définition
des paramètres de ce cofinancement sur
la capacité qui est parfois un peu
hétérogène des structures porteuses qui
sont parfois des collectivités parfois
des consulaires parfois des associations
à supporter ce reste à charge de
cofinancement des postes donc le
programme il est bien il a bien vocation
à être pérenniser avec un une part de
co-financement qui n'est pas majoritaire
mais une part de co-financement des
structures porteuses et puis comme je
disais tout à l'heure une meilleure
coordination un accès à la formation une
meilleure coordination au niveau local
une meilleure coordination entre les
consignes numériques et les autres
acteurs de la médiation numérique qui
soit et d'enconnect déjà bien
identifié comme étant des acteurs de
cette politique là où
les acteurs qui ne se qui sont des
acteurs de la médiation mais qui ne sont
pas identifiés à ce stade comme comme
jouant ce rôle là je parlais des
responsables de médiathèque je parlais
des secrétaires de mairie bref
on a on a bien entendu la nécessité à la
fois de donner un peu de visibilité mais
aussi un peu plus de structures à la
fois sur la formation sur l'organisation
du travail sur le territoire et c'est
tout l'objectif qu'on a fixé aux acteurs
qu'on a fait plancher sur la feuille de
route qui sera donc présentée très
prochainement sur la question de
monsieur le sénateur Bruno Belin moi je
partage votre
souci que les antennes et non seulement
celle du New Deal mais les autres
puissent être le plus facilement et le
plus rapidement déployé pour effacer les
zones blanches les zones grises etc je
crois qu'il y a un certain nombre de
réflexion qui sont en cours qui qui je
l'espère nous permettront d'avancer sur
notamment les questions liées au
littoral où on a encore des difficultés
assez importantes pour le déploiement
des antennes à cause de conflits de
normes qu'à mon avis il faudrait pouvoir
lever on a constaté sur le terrain que
dans certains les les mises en service
des antennes new deal était parfois un
petit peu ralentis par le raccordement
électrique et c'est des discussions que
nous voulons avoir avec enedis pour que
là aussi les choses puissent se faire le
plus
rapidement possible mais compter en tout
cas sur nous pour soutenir les
initiatives
parlementaires ou à défaut à en prendre
si des véhicules s'y prêtaient dans les
mois à venir sur les questions enfin
monsieur le sénateur Guillaume
chevrolier
sur les mesures de la loi reine c'est
intéressant que vous posiez cette
question parce que c'est la même
question que j'ai posé aux auteurs de
l'étude ADEME harcèle qui a été rendu
public lundi
et qui évalue l'empreinte carbone et
l'impact environnemental plus largement
du numérique et qu'il le projette
jusqu'à l'horizon 2030 et 2050 et donc
ma première question a été dire est-ce
que vous avez pris en compte dans la
trajectoire et dans les scénarios que
vous évaluez les mesures que nous avons
déjà prises et en particulier celle de
la loi reine et il est sans doute un
petit peu tôt à ce stade en tout cas
c'est la réponse qui m'ont faite donc je
vais je vais faire la même réponse ici
un peu tôt pour pouvoir estimer l'impact
qui peut le qui peuvent avoir ceci étant
dit si vous aviez des alertes sur la
bonne application de cette loi on est on
est là pour veiller à ce que
l'application soit faite sur le soutien
aux reconditionnement d'abord évoquer
que il y a eu début 2022 un plan de
soutien doté d'une enveloppe de 15
millions d'euros pour soutenir le
secteur avec notamment un dispositif
d'aide visant commencer les entreprises
à court terme enfin de soutenir un
modèle qui reste encore un peu fragile
puis le lancement de travaux avec la
filière du reconditionnement de produits
numériques afin de définir un système de
référence permettant de mettre en valeur
la bonne qualité des produits numériques
reconduits mais ça n'était que une je
dirais une aide de
d'amorçage puisque ce vers quoi nous
avançons ce sont
deux éléments le premier vous l'avez
cité c'est la redevance copie privée qui
sera même si dans la première décision
de la de la commission même si la
première décision de la Commission a été
repoussée par le Conseil d'État une
deuxième décision a eu lieu de la
commission copie privée qui qui réduit
la redevance pour les appareils
reconditionnés c'est qui est un bon
signal est-ce que ça va suffisamment
loin c'est une discussion qu'on peut
avoir les avis sont particulièrement
tranchées et clivés sur le sujet la
deuxième chose que je veux évoquer c'est
que dans le cadre du Plan France 2030
c'est-à-dire les investissements
d'avenir nous sommes en train de
réfléchir à une stratégie d'accélération
pour le vernissement du numérique ça
faisait partie du paquet lorsqu'il a été
annoncé mais cette stratégie
d'accélération est en cours
d'élaboration elle donnera une part très
importante à la question du
reconditionnement puisque comme vous
l'avez dit dans votre question
l'empreinte carbone du numérique c'est à
5% les réseaux à 15% les centres de
données mais à 80 % les
terminaux et si nous voulons contenir
l'empreinte carbone du numérique c'est à
dire la maintenir au 17 millions de de
tonnes équivalents carbone tel qu'elle
se présente aujourd'hui si nous voulons
simplement la maintenir il nous faudra
réduire de deux ans pardon allongé de
deux ans la durée de vie de nos
terminaux et pour ça il faut à la fois
acclimater nos concitoyens à cette idée
là mais soutenir également la filière de
reconditionnement
très bien merci monsieur le ministre
pour les réponses à ces questions il
nous reste cette question chers
collègues donc compte tenu des délais et
des obligations d'un certain nombre
d'entre vous je vous propose de voilà
d'être très concis dans vos questions
parce que l'ordre du jour ne sera pas
terminé après l'audition du ministre
donc si nous voulons avoir le temps et
en nombre de d'abord tous les sujets je
vous propose d'être très concis dans vos
questions une série de cette question
que nous allons prendre à suivre Cyril
pelvat pour la première
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre plusieurs communes de mon
département font état d'acte
devantalisme de leur locaux de fibre
optique le syndicat chargé de
déploiement de la fibre le cyan a
décompté 118 dégradations sur son réseau
entre juin et décembre 2022 et 27 depuis
le 1er janvier 2023 soit un total de 145
au moins de 10 mois malheureusement
situation n'est pas circonscrite à la
Haute-Savoie et les collectivités sont
exaspérées les réparations pèsent sur
leur budget et dégradation après que les
habitants qui se retrouvent parfois sans
internet sur des périodes prolongées
alors que des milliards d'euros ont été
investis depuis 2010 dans toute la
France pour les déploiements de la fibre
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
penser c'est des gains ne sont pas
commises par des voyous et sont
majoritairement du fait des opérateurs
de fibre optiques et de leur
sous-traitants le problème est ici légal
puisque la loi permet aux opérateurs
d'avoir accès à tous les Nero et ne
prévoit pas de sanctions et interdiction
en cas de dégradation la situation
devient tellement indirable que le
syndicat en est venu à mur et
symboliquement des nœuds de raccordement
optique pour protester contre ce
phénomène les élus réclament un meilleur
encadrement du recours à la
sous-traitance des moyens de faire payer
les réparations à l'opérateur ayant
traîné les dégradations ainsi qu'une
interdiction d'accès aux locaux
lorsqu'ils font lorsqu'ils ne font pas
les nécessaires pour que les détérios
détériorations cessent aussi je
souhaiterais connaître votre position à
ce sujet et si vous envisagez des
adaptations législatives réglementaires
pour remédier à cette problématique
je vais faire juste une remarque très
bref puisque vous avez effectivement
répondu à ma question juste on a parlé
de on est le 8 mars on a parlé de de
quasiment égalité entre les générations
sur l'électronisme et en fait là on a
quasiment une égalité également entre
les femmes et les hommes c'est
pratiquement respecté c'est assez rare
donc je voulais le faire remarquer
et c'est à propos contenu de la date
d'aujourd'hui Gilbert Fabro pour une
question
le micro
au bénéficiaire de ces nouvelles
technologies trois points d'abord le
problème
du déploiement de la fibre
des points de la fibre nous savons tous
que l'objectif c'est de déployer
avant la fin 2025 la fibre sur
l'intégralité du territoire national et
là-dessus je regardais l'autre jour la
liste des départements et le classement
dans le pourcentage d'installation de la
fibre je dois dire que le département
auquel j'appartiens les Deux-Sèvres se
trouve à une
83e place qui me paraît pas
correspondre à ce que nous souhaitions
lorsque nous avons sollicité un
opérateur pour mettre cette fibre en
place cette orange pour ne pas le cacher
deuxième point sur
la reprise des infrastructures dégradées
je pense que le problème est le problème
de
la période intermédiaire entre
le cuivre
et la fibre et nous avons là-dessus
effectivement souvent des difficultés
le cuivre qui appartient pour
l'essentiel orange bien le cuivre
et quelquefois maintenu en place mais
surtout il n'est pas en retenue ce qui
pose de d'énormes problèmes pour les
utilisateurs qui n'ont pas la fibre
encore donc c'est la deuxième question
et la troisième question c'est sur le
lien entre l'opérateur de réseau et le
fournisseur d'accès il est vrai vous
l'évoquez tout à l'heure que le bâti de
chaque maison est différent et que quand
le fournisseur d'accès arrive sur place
après abonnement pour mettre en place la
collection il a souvent d'énormes
difficultés j'ai vu ça chez moi c'était
pas facile et donc là dessus est-ce que
vous ne pensez pas qu'il faudrait pour
simplifier les choses comme les
fournisseurs d'accès sont quand même
disciples mettre en place un cahier des
charges ludique qui prévoit toutes les
difficultés prévisibles sur ce genre de
connexion merci Gilbert après les Deux
Sèvres l'Aveyron avec Jean-Claude merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre alors ça complète la question
de mon collègue de gilberté Favreau je
vous souhaitez vous rappeler l'enjeu de
l'entretien du réseau cuivre et du
service de téléphonie universel
orange a officialisé en février 2022 la
fermeture du réseau cuivre d'ici 2030
pour autant le service universel doit
être garanti il nous avait bien compris
le 8 février n'est-ce pas qu'il revient
à larsep et à l'état d'y contribuer
n'est-ce pas et donc madame de La
Rosière nous a confirmé le 8 février que
l'abandon du service téléphonique
universel comme je viens de l'expliquer
elle a pas par ailleurs indiqué que le
ministre vous-même donc délégué chargé
de la transition numérique
euh devait
s'engager à une réflexion pour
l'ouverture d'un nouveau droit d'accès
Internet minimum garanti pour tous les
Français donc on a bien compris ça
l'autre jour ce qui nous a dit Madame de
La redière moi je voulais vous demander
dans tout ce nouveau ce déploiement dans
toutes ces conditions comment
l'entretient du réseau cuivre sera-t-il
réalisé je vous précise que nous avions
saisi avec 14 parlementaires du Massif
central le ministère de la cohésion du
territoire sur ce sujet par ailleurs
merci
très bien merci Jean-Claude Philippe
président mandeli président chaise une
petite question complémentaire
concernant les cyberattaques que vous
avez assez largement évoqué et vous avez
parlé de notre département des
Alpes-Maritimes avec Patricia demach qui
a été fortement touché moi c'est une
question très très pratique pour
répondre à ces cyberattaques des
solutions numériques et existent bel et
bien sur le marché mais le modèle
économique parabolement c'est
fournisseurs posent des difficultés pour
pour les communes au niveau de la
comptabilité publique puisqu'elles sont
considérées comme des dépenses de
fonctionnement qui viennent peser encore
un petit peu plus sur les charges des
collectivités est-ce qu'il n'y aurait
pas la possibilité que au regard des
objectifs elle
puisse fin de la chambre de la sobriété
numérique de la protection des données
être fléchées sur des investissements
plutôt que sur du fonctionnement ça
pourrait aider un certain nombre de
communes merci
monsieur le ministre la lutte contre le
décrochage du mérite est une mission
d'intérêt public mais sur ce sujet ne
pourrait-on pas essayer d'améliorer
l'articulation et l'incrémentation de
l'ensemble des acteurs qui pourraient
être impliqués l'éducation nationale
bien sûr l'émission locale qui suivent
aussi des populations Pôle emploi et
ensuite toutes les collectivités qui
touchent également des publics en
difficulté comme le souligner Martin
filleul les départements par exemple de
telle manière qu'il y ait bien une
mission d'accompagnement numérique qui
soit inclus dans l'émission aussi
d'intérêt général de l'ensemble de ces
parties prenantes et donc c'est aussi un
sujet en soi pour pouvoir accompagner le
maximum de population vous avez cité les
maisons France service mais le premier
point d'accès le premier point d'accès
en termes de réseaux sociaux c'est la
commune c'est la commune
et aujourd'hui la notion de médiation
numérique en termes de métier elle doit
se décliner en termes de compétences qui
doivent s'inclure dans des référentiels
mités comme les secrétaires de mairie
etc et donc chacun doit prendre sa part
et il faut faciliter le point d'accès
communal qui peut être un point d'accès
particulièrement intéressant en la
matière le but du jeu c'est d'articuler
l'ensemble des acteurs de que qu'en
pensez-vous à ce niveau là vous êtes un
spécialiste de l'évaluation des
politiques publiques le but du jeu c'est
d'essayer de voir comment articule
effectivement au mieux pour que ces
politiques se mettent en œuvre de la
manière la plus efficace possible
décidément Denise Saint-Pé pour la
dernière question merci président merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre votre
présence matin devant nous dans le droit
fil de mes deux collègues précédents qui
ont posé des questions sur le passage du
réseau cuivre à la fibre
et l'entretien le grand questionnement
que je me pose personnellement et mon
département fait partie des départements
de pilotes cette
exigence que nous devons avoir
envers les opérateurs donc au-delà du
fait monsieur le ministre que les
collectivités territoriales prennent en
charge cette problématique est-ce que
l'État continuera quand même à être
présent pour veiller à la bonne
exécution des contrats entre les
opérateurs pour ne pas laisser des
territoires de France
en complète des errances d'ici quelques
années je vous remercie
et la sobriété de questions et je laisse
tout de suite les parents à monsieur le
ministre dans le même registre pour les
réponses merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président je m'aperçois que j'ai pas
tous deux pas répondu à l'une des
questions de Monsieur chevrolier tout à
l'heure sur la question du de la bascule
du service universel vers un régime
nouveau puisque le service universel du
cuivre s'est arrêté ça me permet
peut-être d'essayer de ramasser en une
réponse certaines des interrogations que
vous avez pu avoir la vision quelle est
elle la vision du point de vue de nos
concitoyens c'est de pouvoir dans le
monde fibré disposé d'un droit au très
haut débit ce droit au très haut débit à
vocation a remplacer le service
universel d'avant dans le monde fibré
que nous vers lequel nous avançons à
mesure que nous quittons le monde du
cuivre ça veut dire quoi un droit au
très haut débit ça veut dire que ou que
je sois sur le territoire national je
dois pouvoir accéder à un déb it minimum
le débit je l'ai déjà évoqué je le redis
ici le débit minimum auquel nous voulons
que chaque Français puisse avoir accès
c'est 30 mégabits par seconde
le droit au trait au débit c'est un
débit minimum c'est ce sont des tarifs
sociaux pour les Français modestes comme
c'était le cas dans le cas du service
universel ces tarifs sociaux vont faire
l'objet d'une discussion d'une
négociation avec les opérateurs qui fait
que que je compte comme je l'évoquais en
introduction faire aboutir à la fin de
du premier semestre et puis il faut que
aussi du point de vue du de notre de nos
concitoyens il puisse avoir lorsque
ils font face à un raccordement complexe
un coup de pouce une aide à
l'installation pour le génie privé voilà
ce que ça donne voilà la vision du point
de vue de nos concitoyens mais ça veut
dire qu'en parallèle il faut réussir la
complétude c'est à dire qu'il faut aller
jusqu'au bout de de la fibre dans les
zones denses dans les zones amies dans
les zoneries ça veut dire qu'il faut
il faudra garantir la résilience de ces
de ces réseaux et leurs qualités sur des
j'en ai parlé et d'ici là il faut que la
qualité du cuivre soit maintenue
donc ce vers quoi nous voulons aller
c'est ce droit au trait au débit et en
régime de croisière je pense que ce sera
un progrès pour nos concitoyens mais
dans la phase de mise en oeuvre il faut
aussi que les opérateurs nous permettent
d'atteindre cette complétude cette
résilience et cette qualité et que
l'opérateur historique maintienne son
niveau de qualité de service
je vais je vais donc aller peut-être un
peu plus rapidement sur sur les réponses
d'abord
les réponses sur le sénateur Cyril pelva
sur la qualité de la fibre dans votre
département ce qu'on a demandé à la
recette c'est de regarder si nous ne
sommes pas là dans une des situations
que j'ai évoquais tout à l'heure en
introduction c'est à dire non pas des
problèmes
d'attribution de responsabilité entre
l'opérateur d'infrastructure et
l'opérateur télécom mais un problème
d'accidentologie du réseau lui-même lié
à je dirais à son installation à
l'époque où il a été installé si c'est
le cas nous demanderons comme nous
l'avons fait pour d'autres opérateurs
d'infrastructures que nous soit présenté
un plan de reprise générale du réseau
pour mettre fin à ses accidents à
répétition et donc on vous tiendra
informé de la réponse que la recette va
nous accorder
je vais peut-être en réponse à la
remarque de madame la sénatrice Nadège à
bet simplement rappelé que en cette
journée du 8 mars il est bon de dire
qu'il y a pour le numérique et dans les
secteur des télécommunications
des métiers des opportunités
professionnelles dont les femmes doivent
se saisir et cette journée l'occasion de
le rappeler comme vous le savez on a
trois chercheurs sur 10 moins de trois
chercheurs sur 10 sont des femmes moins
de 3 professeurs dans les sciences et
technologies sont des femmes moins de
trois créateurs d'entreprises moins de
trois développeurs dans les métiers du
numérique sont des femmes il nous faut
résorber cette fracture là parce que le
on a un objectif très simple c'est 5 sur
10 parce qu'il y a aucune raison que les
femmes ne bénéficient pas des
opportunités offertes par ces métiers là
je crois que c'est important de le
rappeler
sur les remarques de monsieur le
sénateur Gilbert Favreau dans les Deux
Sèvres nous sommes face à un problème
qui est celui du déploiement dans les
zones amies
ou orange il y a quelques années et SFR
ont pris des engagements lorsqu'on leur
a dit
voulez-vous
déployer dans ces zones-là ou
allons-nous confier ces zones là à des
rips ADN réseau d'initiatives publiques
Orange et SFR ont dit non non je
m'engage à couvrir en fibres ces zones
là
on s'aperçoit quelques années plus tard
qu'une partie évidemment majoritaire a
été fait mais que des retards en tout
cas que une partie de ces territoires
que Orange et SFR c'était engagé à
couvrir ne sont pas encore couverts dans
votre département des Deux-Sèvres c'est
le cas et donc nous avons demandé à
lacep en 2021 de mettre orange en
demeure il y a un contentieux en cours
sur ce sujet mais nous avons bon espoir
de faire en sorte que Orange tienne ses
engagements dans les zones amies parce
que c'est
c'est ce à quoi l'opérateur historique
s'est engagé il y a en temps et sur le
cuivre puisque vous posiez cette
question qu'est-ce qui comment est-ce
que le gouvernement entend faire en
sorte que jusqu'à ce que tous les
Français aient basculé vers la fibre ou
d'autres technologies le réseau cuivre
que nous voulons retirer parce qu'il est
très coûteux à entretenir et parce qu'il
est très énergivore mais qu'en attendant
que qu'il soit retiré qu'il soit
entretenu
le premier Jean Castex en 2021 a obtenu
d'orange l'engagement de
Orange consacre chaque année 500
millions d'euros à l'entretien de ce
réseau là des comités départementaux de
suivi du réseau cuivre ont été mis en
place en principe je sais qu'il y a eu
différentes il y a une hétérogénéité
dans la mise en oeuvre de ces comités et
nous allons écrire très prochainement au
préfet pour leur demander de veiller à
ce que ces comités soient en place de
manière à ce que les problèmes de
d'entretien de réseau cuivres identifié
puisse nous remonter plus efficacement
possible sur les questions de ce
sénateur Jean-Claude anglar je reviens
pas sur ce que j'ai évoqué c'est donc ce
droit au très haut débit qui qui a
vocation à se substituer donc à terme à
ce qui était anciennement le service
universel monsieur le sénateur Philippe
Tabaro je considère qu'effectivement la
cybersécurité est une priorité pour les
collectivités si je comprends bien vous
vous proposez de rendre invisible ces
dépenses là au FCTV par exemple ça a été
le fait pour le Cloud
qui n'est pas très éloigné de ce qu'on
peut faire en matière de cybersécurité
même si je précise que la première des
protections ce sont les gestes barrières
que chacun élue agent de la collectivité
peuvent adopter mais je prends note de
cette proposition et nous l'intérêtons à
nos réflexions
ateur sur la question du sénateur Hervé
gilet le
[Musique]
sur la question du point d'accès
là aussi ça s'intègre dans notre dans
notre réflexion autour de la suite du
déploiement du plan France 3 débit et de
de la et de la politique d'inclusion que
nous voulons mener il est évident que
l'ensemble des acteurs doivent pouvoir
être
mobilisés et l'éducation nationale comme
pôle emploi comme l'émission locale qui
en réalité joue d'une certaine manière
un rôle d'inclusion numérique puisque
c'est dans les classes de nos collèges
que qui est dispensé l'attestation pix
c'est apôle emploi qui est
administrative que sont administrées à
certains membres de tests et de
formation numérique donc l'idée c'est
vraiment sur le fondement d'une
structuration convaincante et fédérative
fédératrice de l'ensemble des acteurs
sur le territoire que ça se coordonne
bien plutôt que comme on peut le
regretter aujourd'hui que ça ça parte
que chacun
mène sa politique dans son coin et enfin
réponse à la remarque de Denis Saint-Pée
je crois qu'il faut rappeler que
aucun territoire ne doit être délaissé
et que tous nos concitoyens ou qu'ils se
trouvent sur le territoire national dans
l'Hexagone et dans les outre-mer doit
pouvoir avoir accès alors une phase de
transition mais doit pouvoir accès à
terme au très haut débit et nous y
veillerons à attentivement
très bien merci monsieur le ministre
pour ces questions avant de conclure sur
ce vous voulez audition je vous propose
aussi si on est d'accord
au président chaise éventuellement de
nous dire un mot son nom était cité au
moins une centaine de fois ce matin
comme à chaque fois qu'on parle de
numérique donc je pense qu'on pourrait
si vous êtes d'accord le président mais
avec plaisir monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le ministre pour vous
propose et pour toute vos réponses qui
sont comme à chaque fois clair et
précises vous le savez le chantier du
numérique est effectivement un chantier
qui donne un grand nombre de
satisfaction et vous l'avez évoqué pour
la partie de la fibre optique mais aussi
par rapport au niveau d'une mobile
et on pourrait donc se dire que
finalement tout va bien mais vous l'avez
compris par l'ensemble des questions qui
ont été posées il y a un certain nombre
de choses ou de points sur lesquels une
attention doit être apportée on a parlé
de la qualité des raccordements les
problèmes d'objectifs des zonami de la
péréquation qui a pas été abordée mais
que je rajoute à la liste je pourrais
aussi parler des problématiques de
fonciers mobiles des problématiques
liées à la souveraineté à la sécurité à
la résilience
à l'extinction du cuivre à l'hiver et ce
chantier globalement si j'avais à le
résumé je le mettrai moi en quatre
volets le volet des infrastructures le
volet de l'inclusion le volet des usages
et le volet de la cybersécurité
aujourd'hui la difficulté qui est donc
celle qu'on peut constater c'est que
quel que soit la brique que l'on regarde
il y a des difficultés des blocages
parce que ces briques sont finalement
interdépendante
donc vous y avez un peu répondu mais je
voudrais vous précisiez monsieur le
ministre votre volonté en parlant de de
cet objectif de premier semestre ne
pensez-vous pas qu'il serait utile
aujourd'hui d'engager un nouveau
chantier un nouveau deal du numérique
qui reprennent l'ensemble des questions
pour faire en sorte que on reconstruise
ce projet du numérique pour les années
qui viennent
[Musique]
merci cher collègue présidente très
rapidement peut-être monsieur le
ministre c'est vrai qu'il faut qu'on ait
une vision globale et une perspective
merci monsieur le Président et on a
alors évidemment c'est pas hasard
puisqu'on est quand même un peu inspiré
par les les travaux des chambres et en
particulier ce du sénate Patrick chaise
l'idée c'est vraiment d'essayer de
construire avec les opérateurs avec les
collectivités aussi il vous a pas
échappé que j'ai parlé de l'ifère de
trouver comment on a su le faire pour le
plan français au début ou l'État prend
sa part ou les collectivités prennent
leur part ou les opérateurs prennent
leur part bref où chacun peut prendre sa
part avec
une vision partagée de là où nous
voulons arriver c'est un peu plus dur
parce que
il faut prendre et enfin il faut il faut
ouvrir plusieurs chantiers en même temps
il faut embrasser suffisamment large
pour embarquer tout le monde mais je
pense que nous y parviendrons et je
l'espère avec votre soutien monsieur le
président
j'invite mes collègues évidemment à
rester en place vous pouvez bouger un
peu